based on the book by Chuck Pollock I'm
not gonna pronounce that comes the film
that inspired an entire generation of
college dorm room posters Fight Club
we're totally about to break the first
rule aren't we meet Tyler Durden but I
died being jack or whatever he's a
normal guy with a steady job nice condo
and plenty of free time which in the
late 90s when something was horribly
wrong with your life everything will
change when Jack creates the impossibly
cool alter ego Tyler Durden up horn
splicing soup kissing soap making badass
who's basically the Che Guevara of
Imaginary Friends follow Jack slash
Tyler on their quest to save us from all
of our first world problems advertising
as it's chasing cars and clothes working
jobs we hate vice we don't need as they
tear down our society of mindless
consumer slaves by building the society
of mindless actual slaves like the
monkey ready to be shot in the face
but since he's so hot barely anyone will
realize he's a total hypocrite ah
these are their secret underground world
of fight clubs the only place where
modern men to release their violent
urges except for boxing wrestling
football mixed martial arts gun ranges
action movies video games hunting mosh
pits hardcore hip-hop and war stripped
down and join in their out-of-control
punch fests and their anarchy obsessed
terrorist group where the only thing
they love more than violence and chaos
is following the rules the first rule of
Fight Club is you do not talk about
Fight Club sir the first rule of Project
Mayhem is you do not ask questions sir
second rule of Fight Club third rule of
Fight Club fourth rule fifth rule six
through seventh rule first rule of
Project Mayhem sir the first rule of
Project Mayhem personal project take a
break from all of the sweaty guy on guy
action to experience some of the other
repressed fantasies like threatening
your boss blowing up buildings sticking
your dick in crazy punching jared leto
in the face and illiterate lots and lots
of littering take that society then
prepare yourself for a twist ending we
all should have seen coming we're the
same person that's right where the movie
does everything it can to show you the
Tyler isn't real the exact same
briefcase
sometimes Tyler spoke for me for some
reason I thought of my first fight with
Tyler this conversation is over
but nothing to explain why shooting
yourself in the face gets rid of them
are you though
so revisit this high budget Hollywood
movie that has an anti-capitalist
message yet features tons of product
placement a spin-off PlayStation game a
graphic novel sequel to collector's
editions and of course officially
licensed so I am Jack's missing sense of
irony
Brad spits stop hitting yourself stop
hitting yourself
the corpse bride Dallas fighters club
babes and Happy Feet Fight Club like
this video if you downloaded this pixie
song off Napster be sure to subscribe
for more honest trailers it's morphing
time at the end of the vid say this P
monkey buds feisty peacock part Stars
and horseshoes clovers and bluebirds
hourglasses rainbows and tasty red
balloons